am freitag übergibt
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
in der maria theresien kaserne in wien
sechs neue busse an die truppe diese
investition ist nur ein teil eines
großen investitionspaket es betont
tanner in ihre rede
wir investieren in die schutzausrüstung
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten und wir
müssen in die mobilität
investieren denn es gibt keinen einsatz
ohne dass die mobilität auch
sichergestellt ist die neuen busse
verfügen über strom und usb-anschlüsse
eine bordküche mit kühlschrank und
toilette und über einen abbiege
assistenten in die neuen fahrzeuge
wurden rund zwei millionen euro
investiert